it was supposed to be a relaxing morning
playing America's national pastime
instead the US Capitol is reeling after
a hail of gunfire just outside of
Washington a gunman opened fire at this
field targeting a gathering of
Republican congressman and others
practicing for a baseball game he
wounded several people before being shot
dead by police one of those hit was
Louisiana Congressman Steve Scalise the
number three Republican in the US House
of Representatives he's recovering at a
nearby hospital
the auto look at Scalise colleague and
top-ranking House Republican Paul Ryan
praised the police response
he called for unity in the wake of the
shooting I asked each of you to join me
to resolve to come together to lift each
other up and to show the country to show
the world that we are one house the
people's house United in our humanity it
is that humanity which will win the day
and it always will god bless I yield US
officials have identified the assailant
as this man 66 year-old James Hodge
Kison from the state of Illinois
authorities say it's too early to say
whether the incident was politically
motivated but eyewitnesses to the
shooting have lamented the country's
deep divides
you can't have this sort of political
division in the nation like America that
we should accept other people's views
and not target them with ak-47 earlier
mass shootings in the u.s. have often
triggered renewed debate about gun
control in the country
but it's unclear whether this latest
incident will have a similar effect
Scalise himself is a fierce advocate for
gun rights and previous debates on the
issue have often only deepened political
divides